Secrets were revealed, questions were answered,
plans were unfurled, and by the time the dust
settled, even secret identities seemed to
be changing hands.
Now we're here to unpack it all.
This is the ending of Watchmen season one,
explained.
Though Angela Abar was the clear main character
for much of the series, at least in Tulsa,
Watchmen also featured two other key law enforcement
officers whose lives were forever tied to
the events of the original comic.
In the HBO series we meet an older version
of Laurie Blake, the second Silk Spectre and
Doctor Manhattan's ex-girlfriend, and Looking
Glass, a Tulsa cop who happened to be near
ground zero on the day Adrian Veidt unleashed
his alien creature to save humanity.
As the season ends, both Laurie and LG find
themselves in the same place, with the same
agenda: Arrest Adrian Veidt for his genocidal
crimes, and keep pushing their investigation
as high as it needs to go, in spite of Veidt's
insistence otherwise.
"Because the world will end."
"Yeah.
People keep saying that, but it never seems
to happen."
So what happens to them next?
Well, it's easy to see them teaming up on
the future of the Veidt investigation and
following it all the way through.
By the time it's all over, Looking Glass might
even join the FBI, and Laurie might finally
be able to move on from the last shreds of
her superhero past.
Watchmen the comic famously reached its climax
with the reveal that Adrian Veidt was behind
the death of the Comedian, and that it was
part of his own massive scheme to "save" humanity
by uniting the world behind a common alien
enemy.
To do that, he teleported a giant squid creature
into the heart of New York City, killing three
million people.
Veidt's bounced around a lot since '85.
He spent a lot of time holed up in his Arctic
sanctuary, Karnak, then was trapped on Europa
for several years, and upon finally returning
to Earth he summoned all of his ego and intellect
and stopped Lady Trieu from taking Doctor
Manhattan's power.
With that in mind, he was convinced he'd be
worshipped as the World's Smartest Man yet
again.
Laurie Blake and Looking Glass had other ideas,
though, and armed with the video Veidt made
for newly elected President Robert Redford
in 1985, they decided to arrest him for the
deaths of the three million in New York, and
for the conspiracy that had continued since,
via intermittent squid rain engineered by
Veidt.
After a strange trial on Europa, Veidt is
presumably headed for another trial on Earth,
but this time he's likely to have plenty of
defenders who hail him as a visionary who
did what he had to in order to save the world.
For all we know, Veidt won't even survive
long enough for a trial, but that might be
what Laurie and LG are angling for.
As for Redford, who became a co-conspirator
in Veidt's plan when he took office, Blake
makes it clear that it would be fine with
her to bring the president up on charges as
well, which means the United States government
is about to be rocked by a lot of upheaval.
Much of Watchmen's season finale is devoted
to explaining exactly what was really going
on with the mysterious Lady Trieu, and it
turns out there's quite a history to mine.
Lady Trieu, the Smartest Woman in the World,
was born to a mother who stole a semen sample
from Adrian Veidt's private vault.
Trieu inherited Veidt's intellect, ambition,
and insatiable ego, and it all led her to
believe that she was the only one in the world
worthy of holding Doctor Manhattan's power.
"If I can take his power, I can fix the world."
As it turns out, Trieu was planning to kill
Manhattan all along, and her Millennium Clock
housed the device that would have allowed
her to do it.
Adrian Veidt was able to stop her at the last
moment with a rain of frozen squid, but while
Lady Trieu is dead, her legacy is not.
Bian, the clone of Trieu's own mother who
served as her daughter, is still alive, and
her massive corporation and its many holdings
will go to her.
Will Bian learn the right lessons from her
mother's hubris?
Will she right the wrongs of Trieu, or will
she in time adopt the same egotistical outlook
on the world?
Lady Trieu's plan to take Doctor Manhattan's
power for herself nearly worked, in part,
because she was using the Seventh Kavalry
plan to also take Doctor Manhattan's power
as cover.
The Kavalry, an extension of the racist organization
known as Cyclops that William Reeves spent
nearly all of his adult life fighting, had
been scheming for years to incite an overthrow
of President Redford, and their fortunes shifted
dramatically when they learned Manhattan was
back on Earth.
Armed with this knowledge and the resources
of Joe Keene Jr., they developed their own
plan to essentially take over the U.S. government.
In the end, their plan failed, and Trieu used
her own resources to vaporize all of Cyclops'
key leadership, including Joe Keene Sr.
The Cyclops is headless, but that doesn't
mean it's dead.
White supremacy has been shown to have a particularly
insidious hold on this world, and it's doubtful
that organized versions of it will vanish
so quickly.
The season finale of Watchmen managed to pack
a lot into its runtime, but one thing the
episode didn't address was the identity of
one of Watchmen's strangest new characters:
"Lube Man."
The character - so named because of his greased,
skin-tight silver suit - appeared only once
in the series proper, and made a very fast
but unforgettable exit via a storm drain.
Ever since, fans of the show have been wondering
who exactly was under all that silver.
The season finale didn't tell us, but HBO's
canonical supplement to the series, Peteypedia,
seems to have spelled it out.
The compendium, named for Laurie Blake's FBI
subordinate Dale Petey, hinted in previous
entries that Petey himself may have adopted
the Lube Man identity, and the entries added
after the final episode aired all but confirm
it.
Petey was Lube Man, and he was snooping through
the investigation via his secret identity.
Angela Abar's life was forever changed by
the events of Watchmen's first season.
She found out the grandfather she never met
was Hooded Justice, and that he was still
alive and still working as a vigilante.
She found out the truth about her friend and
mentor.
She had to reveal her husband was secretly
Doctor Manhattan, only to lose him hours later,
and she had to figure out how to pick up the
pieces after Jon died once and for all.
With all this in mind, Watchmen season 1 approaches
its final moments with the promise of a new
beginning for Angela.
With her children and her grandfather sleeping
safely inside, she walks to her swimming pool
with a miraculously unbroken egg, swallows
it, and remembers something Doctor Manhattan
told her.
"So, you can put them in this egg, and if
I ate it, I could walk on water?"
The season stops short of visually confirming
that Manhattan did imbue that last egg with
his powers, therefore passing them on to Angela,
but according to creator Damon Lindelof, there's
no real ambiguity there.
There's no reason to think all those things
Jon said were leading nowhere, and after all...
Angela was bathed in blue light on the poster
for the series.
The message is clear: Angela Abar is the new
Doctor Manhattan, whether we got to see her
walk on water or not.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.